bientôt monde sait ce qu ici aujourd'hui
on est dans une ambiance plutôt sombre
il vient de malamine you don't know voit
la mine
ça c'est bon c'est bon j'y vais j'y vais
à temps on est aujourd'hui sur un vrai
jeu d'horreur
maïwenn l'ied eyes autant vous dire que
cette fois c'est pas de fumer tue va
falloir chasser avec de l'eau bénite
super on veut tout vous expliquer mais
surtout ne tirez jamais votre casque et
tu viens tu ça ça ça veut dire tu vas
toucher dessus mais surtout ne retire
pas le casque sinon c'est pas drôle
ok whaou ok moi on a vu pinocchio sur le
chemin ya pas de problème ok nous y
voilà bon bah c'est parfait bayer fif et
vos rêves construisait avec nous le
futur nanar un bon le futur déjà n'est
sûrement pas dans un endroit où il ya un
couteau et du sang sur une table mais
beau ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a ici une
boîte
ok donc c'est cet homme que kate entouré
en rouge avant son 1 alors bien je ne te
permet pas 1 qu'est ce que c'est que ça
une sorte de créature qui est assez une
position foetale sur une femme c'est
nawak à l'eau messieurs où êtes vous
stop stop quoi les mecs
qui gueule quoi il dit pas est ce qui
demande un problème fait quand même un
vrai débat ça suffit
bah oui j'avais compris merci pour le
troll a comme par hasard la pièce
disparaît comme par magie c'est
scandaleux et c'est quoi cet endroit
chelou là où on est dans un hôtel
ouais tu fais là mais twitter est un
groupe c'est ça allez hop hop hop
allez tu tabac plus jamais ça hein
à charlie et tu changeras des chaussures
aussi dans la foulée c'est bien une
table en plein milieu d'un couloir
calais l'architecte a fait ça à quoi ça
aucun sens
soit que cette étape fait rentrer dans
le mur est au jeu c'est que tous ici
cette intrigue quoi quelque chose de
bizarre bizarre elle juge charlie heins
charyn protège et vous retirer chez
rallye je vais mourir doit aussi je
comprends pas pourquoi pourquoi est
accosté dans le mur un dix mois la
réponse charlie
j'aimerais bien me secouer là et va te
couper les cheveux et n'a vraiment
changé
ok donc là on arrive dans la pièce la
plus glauque que c'est que ça aof 2 2
est égal à oui oui charlie oui tu lève
la main non tant pis ok comment ça se
passe ici ça lui plaisait pas qu'on va
devoir mettre mais peut-être dans ce tri
qu'un jour je veux pas de chaise de
merde
le mange libyen quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
quoi quoi quoi il lui devant ou derrière
c'est quoi c'est quoi ton jumièges
charlie et je le ferai jamais je cherche
un petit présent sahim fera plus doux
avec ses dix doigts fins d'enfants de 8
ans et demi un bon s'il te plaît porte
tu te plaît chardy ouvre la porte
allez on se casse c'était normal ça
servait à rien cet endroit ça
pousse sur la ils font passer regarder
ça pour rien et cette salle medias
glauque là qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici
eh ben on n'en sait rien bon apparemment
il ya un mange lumière ça tombe bien je
ne suis pas une lumière donc il ne
pourra pas de manger halal a
heureusement que j'ai fais des bonnes
blagues qui remonte alors ça c'est
l'horloge qui y avait chez ma grand mère
et qui m'empêchait de dormir
ah ben ça va utiliser des enfants
charles tu vas prendre ait quitté avant
la fin de la vidéo dans le jeu tu
connais à te le diras entre nous et
madame tout le monde a ce ton mais tu
peux pas servir à quelque chose
charlie de mer où une écriture salle à
manger aller le repas le repas très bien
j'ai tout moi si tu m'as dit c'était un
détail très important encore une flèche
c'est ça la salle à manger un alors
attends attends ya alors qu'ils facebook
est ce que c'est cette viande ou est ce
que c'est eux
ce j'ai peur ta gueule taione à lait la
viande taper le de merde qu'est
ce que toi c'est sa tour c'est ça ton
travail dans la vie un être accroché un
petit chalet du christ quelqu'un passe
non c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
et à la texture d'une viande est
un gros problème
un très gros problème tient le bordel
y'a quoi au final elle est où cette
salle à manger bordel mais non mais
c'est une blague tant que tu me la fait
pas c'est une viande plus permettez
c'est quoi ça elliott qui s'est incrusté
par là je veux plus aller dans la salle
à manger
non non je t'attends pas alors ferme
d'ailleurs
salut ça va quand allez-vous chaise à a
statement chute un peu un côté t'as pas
trop d'amis bon ça peut se comprendre de
ce contrat peut se comprendre
ok c'est le dortoir bon qu'est ce qu'on
fait ce qu aux couches ou est-ce qu'on
joue au vélo alors c'est un jouet ou
c'est un vrai look lui c'est un vrai
vélo où sont les nains sont bénins et
charlie m'énerve à me larguer quoi
maintenant j'ai plus peur qu'on l'ait
pas l'accueillir
non non non non non c'est interdit de
chanter sa taille de chanter tu vois ce
temps là la tuque faut maintenant qu'ils
chantent qui chantent mais qui je
m'entendais néo jetons coq qui chante
comme un gros qu y avait un gosse qui
chantait il est où il est sous un lit
qui chante qui chantent
est-ce que c'est toi jeune casquette
hier de chanter fait du mini vélo
mais tant d'autres au casier
je sais pas moi recherche se désole gtf
cas là j'étais parti parti voir bon ça
vous intéresse pas j'ai compris j'ai
compris celles on le mange lumière et
ben may t'arrêtes quand ces excursions
nocturnes couche-toi au lit ça c'est
mignon ça est ce que c est ce que c'est
ça ta ta maison charlie charlie c'est ça
ton lit tout dans charest tout dans
charlie non je n'y a pas de lumière à
john des bruits un pâté rassuré non
leurs proches les bières ici le monde
lumière ils mangent les lumières aller
ah les chars libyens bien up annonce
charles il vient pas charlie je peux pas
te redonner le tueur coup franc tu es
dans un endroit de merde t'as pas d'amis
un tas seul ami l'accrocher à une chaîne
d'avanies james kottak comprends moi
allez mon petit bout allez allez si je
t'offre des nouvelles sandales
est-ce que tu souffriras - dis-moi aller
à plus ok la discothèque sais pas où
j'entends la burqa c'est qu'on le dit et
à fermer sa gueule
ramenez moi donc les windows 98 la barre
de chargement qui vais juste dix mille
ans serait des plus petites classes qui
se passe actuellement à hautmont gare
ouais je suis là elle semble à rien il
revient aux lyonnais combat les doigts
du sopalin ok c'était moche non pas de
streamer à elles sont mis à parler
d'escrimeur un aller cordialement s
la voilà avec le stress j'ai raté ma
blague de chaos tout le monde put ça